let's take a closer look at what food
technology does for us technologies such
as flash pasteurization improves the
shelf life of our food while
safeguarding it from harmful bacteria
food technology allows us to replace the
air inside the packaging of our food to
preserve its visual flavor color and
texture additional antioxidants keep our
food as fresh as possible for as long as
possible all while protecting it from
spoilage and preserving its best
qualities in our homes we can benefit
from modern eco-friendly refrigerators
that not only keep our food crisp and
cool but use much less energy in the
process
in short food technology allows us to
prevent this and preserve this food
technology in Europe meets the highest
control standards to keep us safe our
food fresh and tasty and our economy
strong food technology for food at its
best